there's the possibility that a star will
explode
near us in the next couple of billion
years but
over the course of the history of life
on earth
the estimates are that
maybe only one
of the mass extinctions you know was
caused by
a star blowing up in particular a
special kind called a gamma-ray
burst and the i think it's the
ordovician solarian
uh silurian ordovician silurian
extinction
420 or so 440 million years ago
that is speculated to have come from one
of these particular types of exploding
stars called gamma-ray bursts
but even there the evidence is
circumstantial
so those kinds of existential threats
are reasonably rare
the greater danger i think is
civilization
changing events where it's a much
smaller asteroid
which those are harder to detect or or a
giant solar flare
that shorts out the grid
in all of north america let's say now
you know astronomers are monitoring the
sun 24 7 with various satellites and
we can tell when there's a flare or a
coronal mass ejection
and we can tell that in a day or two a
giant bundle of
energetic particles will arrive and
twang the magnetic field of earth and
send all kinds of currents through
long distance power lines and that's
what shorts out
the transformers and transformers are
you know expensive
and hard to replace and hard to
transport and all that kind of stuff so
if we can warn the power companies and
they can shut down the grid before the
big
bundle of particle hits then we will
have mitigated much of this now for a
big enough bundle of particles you can
get short circuits
even over small distance scales so
not everything will be saved but at
least the whole grid might not
go out so again you know astronomers i
like to say
support your local astronomers they may
help someday
save humanity by telling the power
companies to shut down the grid
finding the asteroid 50 or 100 years
before it hits
than having clever physicists and
engineers deflect it
so many of these cosmic threats
cosmic existential threats we can
actually
predict and do something about or
observe before they hit
and do something about so it's uh
terrifying to think that people would
listen
to this conversation it's like when you
listen to bill gates talk about
pandemics and his ted talk a few years
ago yeah
and realizing we should have supported
our local astronomer more
well i don't know whether it's more
because as i said i actually think uh
human-induced threats or things that
occur naturally on earth either a
natural pandemic
or perhaps you know a bioengineering
type pandemic
or you know something like a super
volcano right um
there was one event toba i think it was
plus thousand years ago that that caused
a gigantic
decrease in temperatures on earth
because it sends up
it sent up so much soot that it blocked
the sun
right it's the nuclear winter type
disaster scenario that some people
including carl sagan talked about
decades ago
but we can see in the history of
volcanic eruptions even more recently in
the 19th century tambora and other ones
you look at the record and you see
rather large dips in temperature
associated with massive volcanic
eruptions
well these super volcanoes one of which
by the way exists
under yellowstone you know in the
central us i mean it's not just
it's not just one or two states it's a
it's a gigantic region
and there's controversy as to whether
it's likely to blow
any time in the next hundred thousand
years or so but that would be perhaps
not a mass
extinction because you really need to or
perhaps not a complete existential
threat because you have to
get rid of sort of the very last humans
for that
but but at least getting rid of um you
know killing off so many humans truly
billions and billions of humans
the one that there have been ones
tens of thousands of years ago including
this one um
tobi i think it's called where it's
estimated that the
human population was down to ten
thousand or five thousand
individuals something like that right if
you have a 15 degree drop in temperature
over quite a short time it's not clear
that
even with today's advanced technology we
would be able to adequately respond at
least for the vast majority of people
maybe some would be in these underground
caves where you'd keep the president and
a bunch of other important people
you know but the typical person is not
going to be product protected
when all of agriculture is is cut off
right
and when it could be hundreds of
millions or billions of people
yeah starving to death exactly that's
right
they don't all die immediately but they
use up their supplies
or again this electrical first of toilet
paper there you go
dash that toilet paper you know um or
the electrical grid i mean
imagine north america without power for
a year
right i mean we've become so dependent
we're no longer the cave people
they would do just fine right what do
they care about the electrical grid
right what do they care about
agriculture they're hunters and
gatherers
but we now have become so used to our
way of life
that the only real survivors would be
those rugged individualists who live
somewhere out in the forest or in a cave
somewhere
completely independent of anyone else
yeah i've recently i recommend it it's
totally new to me this kind of
survivalist uh
folks but there's a a few show there's a
lot of shows of those but i saw one on
netflix
and i started watching them and there's
they make a lot of sense they they
reveal to you how dependent we are on
all aspects of this beautiful systems we
human have built
right and how fragile they are
incredibly fragile
and yeah this this whole conversation is
making me realize how lucky we are
oh we're incredibly lucky but we've set
ourselves up
to be very very fragile and we are
intrinsically complex biological
creatures
that except for the fact that we have
brains and minds with which
we can you know try to prevent some of
these things or respond to them
we as a living organism require
quite a narrow set of conditions in
order to survive you know we're not
cockroaches we're not going to survive a
nuclear war
you